Hi ihr Lieben!
Ja, was soll ich sagen?
Ich hab euch verrückt gemacht in den Instagram Stories und dafür
möchte ich mich jetzt bei euch entschuldigen.
Ich hab nämlich letztens Kokoswürfel gemacht, die mach ich zwischendurch
immer mal gerne, einfach weil ich die richtig lecker finde.
Das sind so ganz weiche Kokoswürfel mit Schokolade und schmeckt einfach wie so eine Art
Bounty Kuchen finde ich.
Und das zeig ich euch jetzt weil mein Fehler, ich kann's ja nicht auf Instagram zeigen
und euch hier das Rezept nicht präsentieren!
Daher fangen wir jetzt auch
(H: Ich hab ne kurze Frage!)
Ja bitte?
(H: Du meinst eher, dass ICH die Leute verrückt gemacht habe!)
Jaa, eigentlich warst du ja der Schuldige!
Hamza ist immer ganz schlimm, wenn ihr uns auf Instagram noch nicht folgt, dann holt das nach.
Aber seid gewarnt: Hamza ist ganz schlimm! Der probiert immer vor der Kamera
und ganz, ganz viele sagen: "Ich würd gern Hamzas Job einnehmen"
weil der immer ganz viel leckere Sachen probieren darf.
Aber ich werde
(H: Gibt's nicht!)
Hm?
(H: Ist unbezahlbar!)
Gibt's nicht? Gemein.
(H: Ne, ich tausch den niemals ein!)
Okay. Echt gemein. Egal, ich möchte euch jetzt nicht weiter auf die Folter spannen.
Ich hab hier meine Zutaten bereit, ganz klassische Standardzutaten.
Wir fangen hier an mit Zucker, dann hab ich Milch und Vanilleextrakt.
Hier hab ich Sonnenblumenöl, könnt da auch Rapsöl nehmen.
Backpulver, Eier und Mehl.
So. Und jetzt gebe ich zuallererst die Eier, die werden hier auch nicht getrennt,
in die Rührschüssel meiner Küchenmaschine.
Ihr könnt natürlich auch euer Handrührgerät verwenden aber es dauert länger.
Und ich schlage das hier echt so 7min lang auf höchster Stufe
und da geb ich auch schon Zucker und Vanilleextrakt mit rein, weil's dann noch
dick-cremiger wird.
So nach 7min stopp ich hier ganz kurz die Zeit.
DIe Eiermasse ist richtig schön dick geworden und hell-cremig.
Und später kriegen wir daraus einen richtig fluffigen Boden
und den brauchen wir auch.
Ich geb jetzt hier noch die flüssigen Zutaten rein.
Das heißt einmal das Öl und die Milch. Und bei der Milch noch ein kleiner Tipp:
Ich geb sie nicht direkt aus dem Kühlschrank rein, die sollte schon
Zimmertemperatur haben. Notfalls einfach für 10sek in die Mikrowelle geben.
So jetzt ganz kurz einrühren und dann die trockenen Zutaten auch ganz kurz
nur noch einrühren. Und am liebsten vorher sieben!
Macht das damit ihr auch keine Klümpchen im Teig habt.
So, und fertig ist der fluffige Boden!
Und es hat keine 8min gedauert.
Und jetzt gebe ich den auf mein mit Backpapier ausgelegtes Backblech.
Ich mach mal hier ein bisschen Platz und wollte euch noch den Tipp geben:
verwendet gerne einen Backrahmen, damit ihr nicht zu viel Verschwendung habt.
Damit der Teig auch nicht ungleichmäßig backt und an allen Seiten schön gerade ist.
So den Teig hab ich jetzt noch glatt verstrichen mit der Teigkarte.
Und jetzt ganz, ganz wichtig: die Maße beachten!
26x36 cm hab ich jetzt meinen Backrahmen eingestellt.
Bei mir braucht der jetzt im Backofen bei 180 Grad Ober- und Unterhitze 20min.
Maximal 21 aber nicht länger!
Auf die Maße eben abgestimmt also beachtet die Maße, dann dauert's
bei euch auch nur 20min, wenn ihr einen kleineren Backrahmen habt, dann braucht
er länger, weil der Teig höher ist. Andersrum wenn ihr ein größeres Backblech habt,
dann braucht ihr nicht so lang.
So und jetzt geb ich das wie gesagt in den Ofen und wir sehen uns gleich wieder.
So der Boden ist jetzt durchgebacken, ich mach immer ganz gerne die Stäbchenprobe.
Ich nehm mir einfach so einen Schaschlik Spieß oder einen Zahnstocher,
steche das in den Teig und wenn nichts mehr hängen bleibt,
dann ist der Boden durchgebacken.
Und jetzt bedecke ich das noch so ungefähr 5-8min mit einem sauberen Tuch
und lasse das so ein bisschen ausdampfen aber wir schneiden das gleich noch durch
während es noch warm ist.
Jetzt zeig ich euch aber die "Schokoladentränke" quasi
und dafür benötigt ihr ganz einfach 4 Zutaten.
Ich hab hier Milch, dann hab ich Zartbitterkuvertüre, könnt auch gerne Vollmilch nehmen.
Zucker und etwas Butter. Das geben wir jetzt alles in den Topf,
lassen das miteinander schmelzen. So, dass es sich eben verbindet
und wir gleich damit weitermachen können.
So, die Schokosoße ist fertig, einfach nur kurz an die Seite stellen.
Außerdem brauchen wir natürlich auch noch ganz viel Kokos.
Und der Boden ist jetzt auch noch lauwarm. Einmal das Geschirrtuch weg.
Hauptsache ich sag Geschirrtuch. Nehmt euch ein sauberes Geschirrtuch,
obwohl ich selber keine sauberen Geschirrtücher mehr hab,
alle in der Wäsche, nehm ich hier ne Tischdecke.
(H: *lacht*)
Egal!
So, jetzt schnapp ich mir mein Tortenringmesser, nehme jetzt erstmal den Backrahmen ab,
nehme das Ganze vom Backblech runter. Wobei, ihr könntet auch auf dem Backblech schneiden,
das wär hier auch kein Problem.
Aber ich hab ja gleich auch noch meinen Torteneinteiler und dann teil ich mir alles perfek ein,
dass alles gleich groß ist.
So und jetzt nehm ich mir mein Messer(am besten mit Wellenschliff)
und schneide das einmal an den Quadraten entlang.
Und die Ränder, die gönnen wir uns gleich schon, Hamza!
(H: Wirklich?)
Klar!
(H: Oah, geil!)
Und so weich ist der Boden, wie Wolken einfach!
(H: Boah Kiki, kannst du nicht einfach mal einen Kuchen backen, einen Riesen Kuchen...)
Jaa?
(H: und ich leg mich einfach drauf schlafen!)
Okay! Klar!
(H: Man könnt echt drauf schlafen!)
Wie so ne Matratze, so ne richtig super softe Matratze!
(H: Wär schon mal cool!)
Richtig gut! Wir machen jetzt auch direkt weiter.
Der Boden ist ja jetzt auch noch lauwarm. Das heißt wir geben jetzt den lauwarmen
Boden in die Schokolade. Wichtig ist, die Schokolade darf jetzt nicht heiß sein,
die kann auch schon abgekühlt sein. Da müsst ihr euch vorstellen wenn der warme Boden jetzt
in die auch sehr, sehr warme Schokolade getunkt wird, dann könnte es sein, dass es
kaputt geht und das wollen wir ja nicht.
Ich zeig euch das jetzt und dann sind die eigentlich auch schon fertig!
Und fertig sind die Kokoswürfel, die sich eigentlich Cupavci nennen,
das (ich hoffe, ich sprech's richtig aus) ist ein bosnisches Rezept.
Und bevor ihr jetzt in die Videobeschreibung guckt, um euch
die Zutaten zu screenshotten, abonniert auf jeden Fall meinen Kanal.
Das ist so ein bisschen was, was ihr uns zurückgebt.
Wir geben auch ja die Rezepte mit Kiki-Garantie
und daher gerne abonnieren, falls ihr noch kein Abonnent seid,
und dann macht sie unbedingt nach! Sie halten 3 Tage lang,
sind mega, mega soft und ich bezweifle, dass ihr sie 3 Tage lang irgendwie in der Küche stehen habt,
ohne dass sie jeder auffuttern wird.
Unbedingt nachmachen, den Kanal natürlich abonnieren wie gesagt,
ein Däumchen nach oben geben und dann lesen wir und schreiben
in den Kommentaren miteinander. Schreibt mir noch gerne, ob es das irgendwie
in eurer Kultur auch gibt.
Ich glaube in England heißen sie Lamington.
Also es gibt ganz viele Wörter dafür.
Aber wichtig ist, dass sie extrem lecker schmecken.
Hamza und ich gönnen uns das jetzt mit nem Kaffee und euch noch einen
wunderschönen Tag und bis um nächsten Mal auf Kikis Kitchen!
Tschüss!